oh sure we all give cruella de vil a
hard time because she wants to kill a
bunch of puppies to make fur coats
and yeah she is actually the worst for
doing that but let's also not forget who
actually gave cruella the idea in the
first place
what a charming dog thank you spot
yeah she's dalmatian inspirational yes
you saw that right anita our protagonist
outright gives cruella the idea but wait
there's more
long hair short short course or fine
i'm afraid it is a little cause pity but
it was very fine when she was a puppy
redemption stop giving her information
cruella was ready to give up on the idea
until you talked her into it and it
doesn't even stop
there i did leopard spots in the 80s
well dalmatian spots are a little
different aren't they
cozy cuddly classic less trashy exactly
and after she outright says well if we
make this coat
it would be as if i were wearing your
dog
[Laughter]
[Music]
they still tell her that their dogs are
having puppies and that the babies will
their spots don't come to later you're
sure
yes all right anita girl honey real talk
are you trying to get your dogs killed
or what geez
hello internet welcome to film theory a
show that one day hopes a theory-loving
maniac will steal
15 of our theories and those 15 theories
will escape and return to us with 84
more theories for a total of 99 then
we'll write a theory episode about how
the person who stole the theories in the
first place wasn't a villain at all
make it a two-parter and bring us to a
hundred and one it'll make us millions
we'll start a purebred theory farm and
disney will make a movie about our life
story
maybe even a prequel story about the
villain who stole him in the first place
or maybe i'm getting a little ahead of
myself in 1956
dodie smith penned the book 101
dalmatians which introduced the world to
the all-time great villain cruella de
vil a scheming heiress who loves fur
fun fact by the way in that original
story she also loves eating hot peppers
she's obsessed with fire and she may
just be the descendant of a serial
killer who's also the spawn of the devil
and that my friends is why it pays to
read the source material anyway the plot
of the book revolves around cruella's
attempts to steal 15 dalmatian puppies
from her former schoolmate anita in
order to turn him into a spotted fur
coat and wouldn't you know it a year
later in 1957
walt disney himself says hey you know
that book about the demon spawn that
wants to murder a bunch of animal babies
let's turn that into a kid's movie those
were in fact his exact words one
79-minute movie later and history was
made the cruella character is legendary
becoming one of only three animated
characters to appear on the american
film institute's hundred years hundred
heroes and villains list and now cruella
on disney plus because
why not humanize the egregiously wealthy
heiress was like hey i can buy whatever
i want but instead i'm thinking i'm
gonna murder a bunch of adorable puppies
i'm just hoping they keep the part about
her serial killer grandpa in there
anyway what i want to focus on today
is the end of all versions of the story
you see at the end of the original
animated movie
because cruella was buying and stealing
so many dogs the 15 original dalmatians
now total
101 leaving our hero couple of roger and
anita to adopt them all and start a
dalmatian plantation to care for him and
while that's all cute and adorable i
mean that is like
a lot of dogs like a lot a lot of
puppies
it's a wonderful gesture having hundreds
of dogs running around a country estate
in england but from a logistical and
cost perspective it's gonna be expensive
for all you dog owners out there you
know that having
one dog can be expensive now think about
owning 101 dalmatians who need hours of
daily activity
and specialized diets to make sure that
they don't develop bladder stones so
just how much is it going to cost you to
take care of 101 dalmatians
spoiler alert it may just be enough to
make you consider giving cruella a call
the first step and largest one-time
expenditure would be buying a large
estate in the english countryside
the example of what we're looking for
comes from the end of the 1996 film
where the dearlys live in a gigantic
manner that's painted with black and
white spots i mean
look at this thing based on current
prices of english estates in the
countryside the mansion they bought
would cost
at least four million nine hundred
thousand dollars and i'm talking that is
a
bear bare minimum price let's throw in
an extra fifty thousand pounds or
seventy thousand dollars for renovations
like fences and miscellaneous costs
that'll be needed to prepare the puppy
paradise and
already you've spent right around five
million
dollars and before i get into how much
it would actually cost to care for the
dogs i'm gonna get this out of the way
right now do
roger and anita have enough money to pay
for that short answer
yes shockingly in the 1956 book roger's
just a financial wizard that's loaded
with cash
in both the 1961 and 1996 films roger
and anita make
millions overnight after writing a song
and making a video game where they steal
and slander cruella's name and likeness
might want to put some of that money
aside for legal fees guys if cruella
ever comes for ya she's got
herself a pretty solid case now for as
expensive as the english manor might be
the good news is that it means that they
don't have to pay for a full-time dog
walker
dalmatians are one of the most active
dog breeds and a hundred
and one of them would most certainly
require 24 7 health especially if they
were still living in central london
professional dog walkers earn at minimum
35 000
a year and with a hundred and one dogs
to walk each and every day you can rest
assured that that person would be
needing to go
around the clock it's recommended that
no more than four
dogs are walked at once but for the sake
of simplicity let's just say that
they're doing 10 at a time
if each walk is one hour that is still a
hour workday of non-stop walking to get
through all of them as such we're just
gonna estimate that you need to hire two
professional full-time dog walkers
racking up 70
000 in costs for daily dog walks
alone the other nice thing about having
a giant estate for your massive pile of
pups is that it gives us a solution for
the poop
based on a dog poop calculator yes
ladies and gentlemen it is my job to
look this sort of thing up the 101 dogs
would produce
a whopping 32 000 pounds or
14 500 kilograms of poop a year
that's enough to fill up 1882 plastic
shopping bags
each and every day your collection of
sweet lovable pups will be dropping
dookies in excess of
87.6 pounds 40
kilograms of dog turd in a perfect world
he could find a way to sell the waste as
fertilizer
just use it in a garden but wait dog
poop has harmful fecal bacteria and
happens to be highly acidic which means
that it's not typically used for
fertilizer
i researched composting possibilities
instead but that would take
months best bet make a sign that says
free poop make a sign that says free
anything and someone will take it or you
know if all else fails get yourself a
mid-sized tractor and shove it all into
a big hole
oh sure 101 dalmatians just like when
you're a kid it's all fun and games to
think about having a dog or
in this case 100 of them but the
excitement starts to fade when the cold
harsh
reality of dog turd sets in that is why
this channel's motto is ruining your
childhood
and that is also why you should click
the subscribe button right now so you
can take our theories and use them to
ruin someone else's childhood oh
but we're not done today not even close
on top of these expenses the donations
will also need outdoor automatic
waterers we calculated five at about 70
dollars a pop and indoor
four gallon gravity waterers 10 at 106
dollars per
because domations have a unique urinary
system that requires plenty of fresh
water at all times
otherwise they're gonna get kidney
stones oh sure you may think they could
drink from a nearby stream but most
veterinarians agree that
untreated water could run the risk of
bacteria or contamination
throw in 101 dog beds 101 chew toys 101
leashes 101 grooming supplies because
donations shed a lot and 101 dog tags
and suddenly you've just dropped another
600 so let's just take that 5 million
estate out of the total they're just
gonna be living in a normal regular
house
right as such you've hired on your two
dog walkers you've bought a giant pooper
scooper and you've cleaned out the
shelves of pet supplies plus for a bunch
of miscellaneous dog things
in total you've spent about 107
600 and all of that is without even
tapping into the day-to-day expenses
dalmatians require three cups about .75
pounds or 0.34 kilograms of food a day
this equals 75.75 pounds or 35 kilograms
of dry dog food in order to feed
all of them every single day now i know
in this world they're mostly puppies and
puppies eat smaller amounts but they're
gonna grow
so i'm sticking with the three cups of
food a day rule just to make the
estimate easier
it would be best to feed the dalmatians
food that's low in purines to prevent
uric acid from building up in their
bodies thereby preventing the
aforementioned urinary stones so most of
the cheaper
as well as high in protein diets are out
which means that our cheapest option for
101 dogs is gonna cost 186.50
each day multiply that food cost by 365
days and it's 68
000 72 and 50 cents per year
just to feed them all that's without
even mentioning the greenies or wet food
that the dogs could
and should be eating occasionally since
the dogs are gonna be spending a lot of
time outside they're gonna need flea and
tick treatment to prevent the 101 dogs
from carrying a thousand and one fleas
flea and tick treatment would cost at
least 19
405 dollars and 67 cents annually
pet insurance since you never know when
corella is coming back according to
forbes advisor uk the average annual pet
insurance premium in 2019 was 271 pounds
or approximately 22 dollars a month this
means the yearly insurance would cost at
least
38 668.65 and
now you really get a sense of how this
works the numbers really get big once
you have 101 as your constant multiplier
what about vet visits the average cost
for a consultation and diagnosis is 85
with insurance so you're spending at
least 8 561
a year with visits that don't include
medicine surgery or specialized
treatments
throw in annual boosters five thousand
five hundred and sixty four dollars
total a year and you've suddenly added
one hundred and forty thousand two
hundred
seventy one dollars and eighty two cents
in yearly expenses of food and medicine
on top of the already insane hundred and
seven thousand
six hundred bucks we calculated earlier
that is a grand total of two hundred
forty seven thousand eight hundred
seventy one dollars and eighty two cents
for the first
year of ownership alone and of that 210
000 is recurring expenses that are gonna
happen each and
every year afterward and all of that is
also assuming that there are no new
additions
in 2018 a dalmatian gave birth to 18
puppies
now imagine the 101 dalmatians over time
there's going to be a lot of little
puppies born on the property and each of
them is also going to have to be looked
after
each and every one of those new little
bundles of joy is gonna need those
exact same expenses added to the total
so maybe the better financial decision
would have just been to make them into
coats
well wouldn't you know i ran the numbers
on that in a weird twist of fate let's
just say that cruella is actually
successful in taking the 99
soft furred puppies and turning them
into coats how much could she have made
off of those garments well in the 1961
animated film her henchmen say
you couldn't get off a dozen coats out
of the old caboodle honestly they're not
wrong
on the post warped disney math on
conquer maths.com they analyzed the age
of the dogs
studied furrier websites on what fur
could be used and created some admirable
math to turn a bleak subject into a
learning experience that didn't make me
want to cry
in the end they figured out that cruella
would have only been able to get three
fabric-lined fur coats as well as one
muff out of those 99 puppies
not a whole heck of a lot when compared
to the absolute atrocity she's
committing to get that fur
because it is dalmatian fur the jacket
would probably have to be reversible so
the wearer could you know
hide what their jacket is actually made
of which is also what cruella wanted to
make in the book
right now fendi is selling brown mink
reversible fur coats for 27
thousand dollars a pop so three coats in
a muff that's gonna earn you around 65
000 certainly a whole heck of a lot more
cost effective than dropping a cool
quarter of a million each and every year
to keep them alive
until of course you factor in the fact
that you sold your soul in the process
of making those codes but there is a
third happier option in all of this you
find the puppies a good home
just you know a home that isn't yours
you sell them seriously i know these
dogs are human level smart and they all
seem awfully attracted to each other 30
we're keeping the puppies every single
one of them but moments from the books
and movies made me realize that the
owners are totally down to sell some of
these dalmatians
in 102 dalmatians the 2000
sequel in which cruella deville is
hypnotized into being good then
unhypnotized when she hears the bells of
big ben we learned that dipstick one of
the original 15
dogs from the 1996 movie was adopted by
chloe simon
who is also cruella's probation officer
it's a small world and in 101 dalmatians
two patches london adventure
also a sequel not to be confused with
102 dalmatians we see original pup patch
feeling lonely and left out as he's
surrounded by so many other dogs in the
end he becomes an actor on the show the
thunderbolt adventure hour
[Music]
i bring all this up because it seems
like the dogs do want to grow up and
move
out of the house so it may be better for
the dogs and it is most
certainly better for roger and anita's
pocketbooks the selling price of
purebred domination puppies in the uk
range from 1200 to 3 000 pounds or
seventeen hundred to forty two hundred
dollars
if each litter averages six to nine
puppies that means they could be making
at least
ten thousand dollars per liter
dalmatians can start giving birth at six
months so they could make a lot of money
at the plantation by selling the
purebred dalmatians to worthy owners if
let's say
30 of the dalmatians have two litters
each and every year that's 360 puppies
selling them all results in somewhere
around 612
000 per year in dog earnings and that's
on the low end because these are indeed
famous dogs as we see in the 101
dalmatians 2 movie they'd probably net
the high end of the asking price
totaling nearly one and a half million
dollars per
year in earnings and considering that
roger and anita are good people that
care about these animals the puppies
will be healthy and the business
transactions will be honest with these
sorts of numbers the puppy plantation
could hire more staff
buy more land even start taking in more
animals like the deerleys actually do in
the 1956 book where believe it or not
they even adopt cruella's abused cat
in the end while the theft of their
beloved puppies must have been
heart-wrenching
every cloud has itself a silver lining
it opened up the dearly's hearts to a
hundred puppies and it opened their
pocketbooks to make millions off of hit
songs popular video games and of course
their side hustle of selling dalmatian
purebreds
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and i'd like to give a very very
special thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video
nord protects you and your data on the
internet by keeping it safe behind a
wall of next generation encryption
so when you're doing questionable things
on the internet like say uh doing
research into the logistics of skinning
donations for luxury coats you can rest
easy knowing that your data's secure
as you might be able to imagine it's
nice to know that that search history
ain't gonna be following me around
with vpn servers located around the
world nord allows you to enjoy the
internet with no limits
no borders giving you access to versions
of websites that are unavailable to you
at your current location so let's just
say for a moment that you live in a
country where disney has taken
all of their classic movies and put them
in a vault waiting for you to pay for
disney plus
oh wait that's literally every viewer in
the united states well thanks to nordvpn
you don't need a disney plus
subscription to watch those
in just two clicks you're suddenly in a
different part of the world where you're
able to stream movies like ant-man and
spider-man homecoming using netflix
canada or let's say you have the
inescapable urge to stream
jack black's classic school of rock
every waking moment you can just hop
over to netflix uk to get your fix or if
that's not enough jack black for you
and believe me it may not be you can hop
over to netflix canada again and watch
kung fu panda right after plus
nord gives you the ability to connect up
to six devices on one account so no
matter whether you're using your
computer phone or tablet nord has got
your back and with their strict no log
policy i can feel secure knowing that
they're not tracking collecting or
sharing
any of my private data right now our
friends at nord are offering a huge
discount on a two-year plan at
nordvpn.com
film theory it's in the top line of the
description plus if you use the code
film theory at checkout you get an
additional month for free they offer a
30-day money-back guarantee so it really
truly is risk-free again that's
nordvpn.com
film theory unlock the world's internet
and feel safe browsing
using nord and as always i'll see you
all next week